she said I'm never going to try and
change you to me that was very freeing
it was just pure acceptance if you can
find somebody who just accepts you like
truly isn't like hey you should dress
this way hey you should cut your hair
like this there's big implications in
that statement it's I don't care what
you want for you I want you to look like
this for me you could make the argument
well I'm the one who looks at you all
day and you want me to be attracted to
you Etc but like in my opinion I think
it works better if you were attracted to
that person's natural state if the way
they act the way they dress the way they
are is someone that you are attracted to
then I think that's the game I think
you've won